[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire que c'est pour vraiment sur
l'origine du corona virus le sar skov 2
l'anc est mené par l' oms en chine n'a
pas permis de mettre fin aux soupçons
l'hypothèse du virus transmis par un
animal à l'homme reste la plus partagée
mais celle de l'accident de laboratoire
a de plus en plus de partisans y compris
chez les scientifiques quant à
l'hypothèse du marché de yuans
d'où les premiers cas avaient été
rapportés en décembre 2019
elle semble aujourd'hui abandonnée mais
bon toutes les hypothèses restent
ouvertes a déclaré le directeur de la ms
alors pour débattre des hypothèses nous
avons invité brice perrier journaliste
indépendant vous collaborez notamment à
l'hebdomadaire marianne vous traitez
surtout de sujets scientifiques
vous venez publié sarr skov 2 aux
origines du mal aux éditions belin dans
lequel vous raconter comment et pourquoi
la fausse piste du pangolin a permis
d'écarter ou de négliger d'autres
scénarios plus dérangeant alors en deux
mots pour l'instant vous vers quelle
hypothèse vous vous penchez vous
espériez
moi je me suis penché sur toutes les
hypothèses en fait parce que j'ai fait
un travail de journaliste une enquête et
qui m'amène pas à trancher et affirmer
que c'est telle ou telle hypothèse qui
l'emportent par contre c'est vrai que
j'ai pas mal exploré l'hypothèse du
laboratoire qui était quand je me suis
penché exclu quasiment du débat sous
couvert de conspirationnisme on va voir
ce qu'il en est en réalité
alexander samuel vous vous êtes docteur
en biologie moléculaire enseignants
lanceur dallaire sur les gaz
lacrymogènes
vous avez été très actif depuis le début
de la crise du coc vide 19 notamment
pour lutter contre la désinformation
alors vous vous penchez veut en faveur
de quelle hypothèse plutôt à moi je pars
et je ne veux pas affirmer l'hypothèse
avec certitude par contre se soient
échappés dans la boîte ans ça me paraît
plutôt improbable eh bien on va en
reparler mais d'abord la première
question que j'aimerais vous poser c'est
pourquoi la
la piste du pangolin at-elle été
privilégiée dès le départ dès le départ
on a parlé du pangolin du pogo l'aide du
pogo là est-ce que vous avez une réponse
euh oui ce père y est bien oui c'est pas
vraiment dès le départ mais c'est assez
vite parce que ses débuts au début du
mois de février il y à l'université de
chine du sud qui a fait une conférence
de presse en présentant une découverte
qui étaient des virus 2d coronavirus
trouvait chez des pangolins qui aurait
affirmé t-il 99% d'identité avec sarko
vaut deux ce qui est une identité donc
très importante et qui pourrait
correspondre à l'autre intermédiaire qui
aurait transpire transmis le virus à
l'homme ça c'est une information qui a
fait le tour du monde
immédiatement qui a été tout de suite
relayé par le journal nature est alors
qu'en fait il s'est avéré que c'était
faux parce que l'identité des virus de
pangolin n'était que de 90 %
donc ce qui l'est plus du tout la même
chose et mails et cette idée a fait son
chemin a été a été propagé ensuite il ya
des articles qui ont entretenu un peu
cette idée des articles sont hautement
parue dans nature qui est entretenue
cette idée que le virus pouvait venir du
pangolin mai mais c'était en fait moi je
vois c'est un peu comme une sorte de
diversion en tout cas comme une
affirmation qui n'était pas du tout
avéré alexander semelle oui alors c'est
la méthode classique en août il faut
comprendre quand on exporte des
hypothèses il faut essayer de réfléchir
comment on peut répondre
philippe aux thèses donc là il ya trois
hypothèses possibles pourraient venir
dans laboratoire que ce soit une arme
chimique ou autres venir gueuler pardon
qui est développée ou quelque chose qui
est pas du tout une arme et un accident
de laboratoire parce qu'on essaie de
prévenir des infections ou alors c'est
une zoonose est donc évidemment avec
trois hypothèses devant nous et pour
pouvoir trancher
la méthode classique on va employer
c'est de regarder un petit peu la
séquence génétique on va commencer par
regarder un peu les
et puis on va regarder s'il ya des
hommes aux jeux dé homologie de
séquences avec des choses qu'on connaît
déjà
donc effectivement pas le problème c'est
au départ cadets la séquence du sascoc 2
quelle est la séquence de ce nouveau
virus
parce que au début on va c'est quand
c'est chez le premier individu qu'on va
détecter mais c'est peut-être pas la
séquence la plus consensus comme on dit
c'est à dire que c'est pas on a détecté
une personne on est sûr que c'est une
nouvelle maladie on va regarder ce que
c'est mais c'est peut-être pas cette
personne qui a la séquence qui est la
plus générique
elle a peut-être une tout de suite des
variants a tout le temps des variations
puisque toujours des erreurs de copies
et donc on va essayer de décrire une
séquence consensus par rapport aux
premières séquences qu'on va faire et
puis celle ci va peut-être se rapprocher
plus de tel ou tel organisme au départ
et puis quand on sait qu'en cet avantage
chez plus de personnes on va avoir des
séquences qui vont me consensus qui va
un peu évolué on va avoir des spectres
de varien qui va évoluer
donc oui effectivement au départ il ya
eu cette proximité qui a été établi avec
le point gaulle 1 et puis rapidement on
a trouvé d'autres proximité notamment
avec cette fameuse est ratée g13 de
chauves souris
alors justement ce que ce que l'on a
l'air de tout le monde a l'air d'être
d'accord c'est que le sarc off devient
de chine et qui viennent la chauve
souris mais qu'il a eu besoin d'un autre
animal intermédiaires ont passé à
l'homme est-ce qu'on aurait bien là
est-ce que j'ai bien compris
pas forcément que ça vient de la chauve
souris à la base c'est à peu près acquis
c'est même certain
par contre qui a eu besoin d'un animal
intermédiaire c'est l'hypothèse qui est
privilégiée
que ce soit le pangolin ou maintenant on
parle pas mal du vison ou ça peut être
d'autres animaux mais il n'est pas
exclut totalement que ça vienne
directement de la chauve souris parce
que il y a eu des notamment il ya des
contaminations qu'ils peuvent avec des
cornes un virus dans le sud de la chine
avec des personnes qui vivent à
proximité des chauves-souris donc mais
c'est quand même assez rare mais c'est
pas totalement exclu de sa star viennent
directement de la chauve-souris
alexander s'appelle we say
les hypothèses sont ouvertes un peu on
pense effectivement le ms pense qu'il
faut un autre intermédiaire dans son
rapport à un gros rapport qui est sorti
il ya une hypothèse qui moi m'avait plu
à titre personnel qui n'est pas
nécessairement l'hypothèse la réalité
mais qui me plaisait pas mal c'était
sale publiés par un certain bill galère
qui explique surtout la présence d'un du
site de clivage curie je pense qu on en
reviendra dessus et qui passerait par
des recombinaisons entre plusieurs
séquences de virus chez la chauve souris
donc en fait il faut des coûts
infections ce qui est possible qu'on est
en même temps deux infections par deux
séquences virales différentes en même
temps et dans ce cas là on peut avoir
des recombinaisons des hybridations
trouvé deux séquences il est aussi
possible ça régulièrement génétique
inquiet des tout simplement des rues
pour miner zon avec des choses qui
traînent et qui ont démoli j de
séquences donc l'hypothèse de
combinaisons existe aussi je vous
propose d'écouter tous les deux le la
réponse que m'a faite
antoine flahault que j'ai reçus dans
cette émission la semaine dernière
antoine flahault si le directeur de
l'institut de santé globale de
l'université de genève c'est quelqu'un
que j'atteins vivent depuis le début de
la crise du cornet virus tesi mans et
qui est toujours un peu à la pointe des
connaissances scientifiques parce qu'il
a un regard global justement alors je
vais poser la question de ces
différentes hypothèses ou est-ce qu'on
en ait et et voilà sa réponse et et ça
va relancer le débat
c'est pas tellement le marché aux
poissons en réalité le marché aux
poissons a été assez rapidement éliminés
on a cru au édition du marché aux
poissons mais tout de suite il ya
quelque chose qu'une grotte qui cloche
dans le marché aux poissons ce qui
cloche c'est que les personnes qui ont
été contaminées au marché aux poissons
qui sont arrivés à l'hôpital était dans
un état de santé extrêmement délabré
il avait des pneumonies très sévère or
on sait maintenant très bien que on peut
avoir une tenue très sévère qui vous
emmène en réanimation avec cette maladie
mais que quand on a pour un cas de
pneumonie très sévère c'est vous même
qui avait rappelé ces chiffres on a au
moins 85 cas qu'ils sont
bénin et qui circulent dans la
communauté donc s'il y avait eu un cas
là ces sept cas de pneumonie tracé vert
hospitalisés avoua dans cette période là
on aurait on se serait attendu à ce
qu'il y ait plusieurs milliers de cas
dans la ville de wuhan déjà circulant et
donc probablement le marché est un
cluster mais ça n'est pas plus que cela
ce n'est pas l'origine l'origine il faut
la chercher sans doute même quelques
semaines auparavant alors commande ou
via l'origine et je crois qu'il ya deux
grandes hypothèses soit sur la table
l'une c'est que peut-être des fermes par
exemple devise on aurait pu être
contaminé par une chauve souris
porteuses du coronavirus le coronavirus
ce serait aurait infecté le troupeau de
vison et jeudi le visons pas ce qu'il
y'a d'être beau de visons dans la
banlieue de wuhan
c'est c'est très prisé pour sa fourrure
est donc un peu comme au danemark ou
même en france on a des élevages de
visons et que le vison est un assez bon
modèle animal c'est à dire que c'est
c'est pas un réservoir mais c'est ce
qu'on appelle un autre amplificateur on
peut le contaminer et lui-même peut re
contaminés à son tour des hommes et ça
peut être un bon hôte intermédiaire pour
faire que le virus s'habitue entre
l'homme avec lequel une vison vie et
l'animal alors qu'entre la chauve souris
et l'homme on n'a pas des contacts très
fréquents donc ça c'est une première
hypothèse
malheureusement les les experts n'ont
pas pu avoir accès à des troupeaux de
visan n'ont pas pu faire des
prélèvements sur les quelques troupeaux
de bisons qui étaient dans des fermes
avoisinantes et la deuxième hypothèse
sur la table c'est qu'en effet il puisse
y avoir une
une fuite de laboratoire très
probablement pas du tout malveillantes
pas intentionnel juste une sorte de
négligence une sorte de possibilité que
quelqu'un soit s'infectent en cours
d'une manipulation sur des coronavirus
dans le laboratoire soit que
voilà on casse une éprouvette et que un
virus soit relargués dans la nature
alors l'idée que ça puisse arriver n'est
pas quelque chose de complètement
absurde c'est pas complotistes de penser
cela
c'est pas totalement absurde parce que
il y avoue anne des laboratoires de
haute sécurité un peu comme on a en
france à lyon qui sont des laboratoires
entre un site très bien sécurisé mais
qui ne sont jamais à l'abri d'une fuite
de ce genre et que par ailleurs on sait
qu'à avoine
il y à des recherches qui sont menées
sur des coronavirus est donc ce qu'il
faudrait et cela non plus les experts
n'ont pas eu accès à l'ensemble des
données là dessus c'est d'avoir la liste
de tous les travaux menés avec tous les
germes identifier car tout cela dans un
laboratoire bien conduit doit être
entièrement enregistré entièrement
documenté airs traçable et là on
pourrait savoir s'il y avait un virus
proche de ce que de celui que l'on a que
l'on à aujourd'hui qui a émergé avoue
anne ce que dit la responsable des
recherches sur le coronavirus de ce
laboratoire
c'est que au début quand elle a entendu
parler de cette épidémie qui démarrait
avoir mal dormi parce qu'elle a eu peur
que ça puisse être une fuite de son
laboratoire et qu' elle a vérifié les
séquences et qu'il n'y avait aucune
proximité entre les séquences des germes
qu'elle analysait et ceux qui sont à
l'origine de cette pandémie
on ne sait pas aujourd'hui totalement le
fin mot de l'histoire
je pense qu'il ya des risques qu'on ne
le sache jamais la chine n'est pas connu
pour sa grande transparence et par
ailleurs lui la mission de m es ce que
vous avez mentionné est quand même
arrivé plus d'un an plus tard avoue anne
pour faire cette exploration cette
investigation
alors on va reprendre tout ça
progressivement
premièrement le fait que l'hypothèse du
marché et totalement écarté aujourd'hui
est ce que vous êtes d'accord
vous espériez je dirais pas parce que
la mission de l'om s et la chine awan
fin janvier début février a beaucoup
s'est beaucoup intéressé au marché est
encore dans ses conclusions il ils
disent en gros que la piste la première
piste à explorer ce sont les fermes qui
attribuait d'aidé qui amenait des
animaux au marché avec l'idée que ces
fermes pour avoir des animaux qui
viennent de l'extérieur de la chine
parce que l'une des idées fixes un petit
peu de la chine c'est de dire que ça
vient de l'étranger donc alors même que
comme disait le monsieur le tout laisse
penser que la marché a plutôt est un
cluster qu'une origine
d'ailleurs les premiers malades
identifiées n'avait pas de contact avec
le marché
on entretient que même cette idée du
marché notamment pour trouver cette
piste zone nautique et de dire que ça
pourrait être la dernière nouvelle de
dernière animal met en avant pendant la
mission douanes c'était le blaireau
furet donc il fallait aller chercher
d'où venait le bureau furets et des
blaireaux furet donc aucun n'a été testé
positif aucun animal il ya eu quelque
80000 l échantillon d'animaux qui ont
été testées avec aucun positif au sart
skov 2 mais on insiste pour dire que ça
doit être ça qu'il faut en chercher
d'autres est allé chercher les
fournisseurs du marché peut-être des
blaireaux ou d'autres animaux mais ne
l'a pas enterrer cette piste en tout cas
alexandre dans ce mail dont le rapport
que j'ai eut consulté de l'om s ils ont
quand même effectivement analysé
énormément d'animaux ils ont regardé
beaucoup de choses et il semble indiquer
que c'est probablement pas là que c'est
apparu d'autant plus qu'ils ont montré
qu'ils avaient des personnes qui étaient
positives par le passé avant au mois de
novembre
il ya par exemple il ya beaucoup de
rumeurs qui circulent pas plus tard que
la semaine dernière et à une personne
danser anecdotique mais une personne qui
me dit
l'avait attrapée déjà en mars 2019 ou
qui quittent des dates très très
ancienne c'est très improbable que cela
ait circulé à cette époque là il ya eu
le mfc dans son rapport a fait un
travail aussi épidémiologique qui a
regardé s'il y avait une augmentation
des risques de faire des décès causés
par les infections respiratoires les
choses comme ça et on ne voit pas une
augmentation nette avant le mois de
novembre décembre
donc il ya eu des cas qui ont été
détectés un peu avant ce marché du wan
ces histoires là donc ça a pu circuler à
babou yara mais c'est qu'elle est de
l'ordre de quelques semaines c'est pas
de l'ordre de mois ou d'années
donc on a on avait peut-être une
circulation un petit peu a vanté un
événement qui a pu faire apparaître et
effectivement je pense que ce qui risque
dit antoine flahaut est très très
intelligente parce qu'il dit on pourra
jamais avoir le fin mot de l'histoire
et c'est ça qui est problématique c'est
que quand on explore les pistes en
disant est ce que c'est issue du
laboratoire et qu'on pose cette question
là on pourra toujours trouver un moyen
pour dire que pour le rattacher au
laboratoire et ça va être extrêmement
difficile
moi la question que j'aime bien poser
enfin je me permets de la pause et de
changer un peu de sujet de questions
c'est ce que je veux la plus pertinente
à poser c'est est ce que ça aurait pu se
produire naturellement
est-ce que c'est l'apparition de ce
virus aurait pu avoir lieu sans
l'hypothèse du laboratoire et après je
ne placerai un peu comme la place face à
napoléon en disant je n'ai pas eu besoin
de sites hypothèses pour pour dire que
ça a pu apparaître sans cette hypothèse
donc que ça aurait pu de toute façon à
paraître ce serait peut-être sont
apparus même sans laboratoire même sans
intervention humaine
alors justement posé cette question mais
mais j'ajouterai par exemple avec les
visons dont parle antoine flahault est
ce que ça aurait pu apparaître d'après
vous
naturellement via les visons alors ça
c'est une hypothèse qui tient la route
effectivement voilà c'est quelque chose
qui est tout à fait possible à mon sens
je sais pas s'il voulait pas répondre
excusez moi mais ça aurait pu arriver
naturellement c'est c'est sûr et
d'ailleurs ça a été un fait un argument
notamment de l'article de référence qui
a été écrit par christian andersen et
trois ou quatre autres auteurs qui en
fait dix ex comme ça pouvait être
naturel en fait c'était naturel mais
c'est un peu l'idée qui a eu dès le
départ comme ça peut être naturel c'est
naturel alors qu'en fait un virus qui
sort d'un laboratoire peut avoir tout
d'un virus naturel qu'il ait été trouvé
et collecter et de s'en être modifié ou
qu'ils aient été travaillé avec qu'est
ce qu'on appelle des expériences de gan
fonction qui qui recherchent le naturel
dont ils recherchent une évolution
naturelle qui pourrait arriver
donc ce sont des virus qui ressemblent à
des virus naturel et quant au vison oui
c'est une possibilité
moi j'ai trouvé que ce qui était
intéressant
l' avantage avec le vison c'est ce qui a
fait remarquer comme cet animal c'est ce
qui s'est passé en italie ou en fait on
a eu peu près le premier variant
significative de farce co2 qui est
apparue dans une zone rurale où il y
avait une concentration des élevages de
visons et là ça pourrait expliquer ce
premier variance par un aller-retour
hommes visons retour à l'homme et donc
on a aussi vu par la suite au holland au
danemark plutôt qu'ils avaient eu ce
genre d' échanges avec des retours avec
des mutations donc ce qui a amené
l'abattage de tous les animaux donc
c'est une possibilité après les visions
je sais pas s'il ya des élevages de
visons à proximité de voile parce que
les élevages de visons sont plus dans
l'est du pays et mais il est possible
qu'une chauve-souris ce soit et déféquer
dans l'est et et déféquer dans l'est
dans les mangeoires d
les animaux et leur ai transmis un virus
et qu'ensuite ils soient passés aux
éleveurs et qu'un éleveur à yahoo had et
voilà ça ça pourrait être une piste
possible
alexander sa mère je peux vous poser la
question autrement
quels sont les éléments qui penche
d'après vous vers un virus naturel
alors pour moi c'est la manière de poser
la question de savoir si ça peut se
produire naturellement c'est de regarder
les séquences génétiques et de se dire
bon on va prendre une séquence de
référence en prend une séquence un peu
éloigné de la même famille de virus
et puis regardez quelle étape
intermédiaire ya entre celle ci et le
zares skov 2 qui apparut et puis là on
peut faire des arbres phylogénétiques on
appelle ça à vos phylogénétique on va
regarder le nombre de différences
quelques combien il y a qu'est ce qui a
changé live alors les différences elles
sont elles apparaissent naturellement
parce que chaque virus se réplique avec
une réplique à la réplique à traîne
recopie la séquence
elle va faire des erreurs à chaque fois
et à chaque erreur ça va faire une
petite modification
et donc si c'est naturel à mon sens
fondamentalement la question qu'on va
poser c'est est ce qu'il ya des
modifications régulière est qu'il
apparaît régulièrement une modification
puis une autre puis une autre puis une
autre où est ce qu'il ya un espèce de
saut d'un coup sec d'une d'une séquence
à une autre là pour l'instant
pour vraiment à donner une idée générale
ceux qui sont un peu spéciales hors jeu
ça peut être un débat c'est un objet de
débat chez les spécialistes de dire est
ce que c'est vraiment régulier ou pas
mais j'ai l'impression j'espère que on
sera tous d'accord que le consensus est
à dire qu'il ya quand même pas mal
d'intermédiaire que ça a l'air plutôt
régulier il n'y a pas un énorme bon d'un
point de vue séquence là où il ya un bon
c'est effectivement le gamer function
qui a été évoquée donc il ya peut-être
des fonctions qui change ça je veux bien
qu'on en discute après par contre au
niveau de la séquence de l'évolution des
séquences là c'est plutôt régulier quand
on prend les intermédiaires il n'y a pas
un énorme bon il n'ya pas un énorme trou
à mon sens ce qui expliquerait que il ya
une intervention humaine une
accélération de l'évolution à tel ou tel
endroit donc
citant un petit peu a montré plutôt qui
a une qui est quelque chose de naturel
maintenant on pourra jamais exclure que
quelqu'un à imiter la nature à un moment
donné mais si la nature est capable de
le faire
le fait que quelqu'un illimité de la
nature alors ça c'est intéressant d'un
conduit enquête
si on veut chercher un coupable la
culpabilité mais d'un point de vue
risque que ça se produise ce n'est pas
intéressant soit c'est à dire que si ça
pouvait se produire naturellement même
si c'est quelqu'un qui n'a fait face à
rochus produire naturellement à peu près
à la même période de temps et ça devait
même se produire naturellement dans un
temps donné d'ici 10 ans ou 15 ans donc
ça se serait produit espériez pas disons
que qui est pas de grosses différences
d'évolution entre les virus proche de
charges kof de essar skov 2 je suis je
suis pas sûr parce qu'il ya quand même
des autres particulière de ce virus qui
sont très différentes en fait des des
virus les plus proches
et donc on ne comprend pas justement
comment s'est passée de le virus qui est
le plus proche c est raté g13 qui a été
trouvée par le laboratoire de one en
2013 et qui a été sorti avant avant de
la piste du pangolin il a été sorti dès
le mois de janvier par par la
laboratoire deux églises chic et là
qu'on surnomme batwoman parce qu'elle
est la spécialiste mondial les
coronavirus de chauves-souris et ce
virus qui à 96% d'identité il
il n'a pas du tout le même domaine de
liaison qui est une zone très importante
parce que c'est ce qui permet au virus
de s'attacher à la ceni ben oué c'est
lui l'animal et il a aussi ce que
monsieur évoqué tout à l'heure un site
furent in key qui renforce fortement son
pouvoir d'infection et dont on ne
connaît pas la provenance et il se
trouve quand même que c'est ajouter des
herbes et des des domaines de liaison et
des sites urines à des virus pour
anticiper leur évolution
ça fait partie typiquement des travaux
que deux gains de fonctions que font le
laboratoire de one notamment en
collaboration avec un laboratoire
américain qui est dirigée par un
monsieur qui s'appelle ralph barriques
et donc depuis 10 15 ans il travaille
beaucoup à apporter à faire des chimères
entre des virus pour l'année doté de
bons domaines de liaison et
éventuellement éventuellement de
rajouter un site sur in pour pourvoir ce
que pourraient être des virus dangereux
à potentiel pandémique et le problème
aussi c'est que tout c'est toutes ces
séquences de virus qu'on aimerait voir
en fait des pour avoir une évolution et
ben tout la banque de données du
laboratoire de wuhan a été mise hors
ligne
trois mois avant l'apparition de la
pandémie au mois de septembre et il ya
des virus qui sont dedans dont on est
donc tous les spécialistes aimerait
avoir la séquence complète et qu'on ne
connaît pas et notamment huit bêtes à
cornes un virus de type sarce qui ont
été trouvés dans la même mine où a été
trouvée est ratée g13 et c'est quand
même assez bien peu décevant quoi qu'on
ne puisse pas savoir ça parce que c'est
des éléments essentiels et la chine ne
l'est ne donne pas là la lecture quoi
mais juste une minute avant la pause une
réponse courte mais il ya une chose qui
est très intéressante qui a été fait par
une scientifique qui s'appellerait m
kraft qui a regardé par exemple les
différences qui avait entre les une
séquence consensus avec une séquence de
référence consensus c'est à dire à peu
près c'est qu'en général générique on va
dire de de sascoc et puis les ratés g13
et le sort ce kof 2 et puis elle a
montré qu'il y avait des différences
récipient le même nombre d'occurrences
de différence dans toutes les régions
certes ya pas qu une région qui était
plus modifié qu'une autre sur le virus
toutes les régions ont des différences à
peu près identique que ce soit il ya
plein de régions dans la lancée quand
bruxelles ont toutes à peu près le même
nombre de modifications
j'espère y a pas l'air convaincu on fait
une pause et on continue ce débat
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur les origines du
sart skov de le virus
le fameux virus qui nous empoisonnent
depuis plus d'un an maintenant avec
maurice perrier qui est journaliste et
qui publie sarr skov 2 aux origines du
mal aux éditions belin et avec alexander
samuel qui est docteur en biologie
moléculaire
première question pour eux de repartir à
votre avis vous espériez pourquoi
l'hypothèse de l'accident de laboratoire
at elle été rejetée dès le départ ça
s'explique par l'intervention en fait on
peut dire de d'une personne qui
s'appelle peter d'azac qui est le
président d'une ong qui s'appelle échos
health alliance qui eux qui travaillent
à collecter des virus dans le monde pour
pour prévenir des pandémies pour
connaître en fait les virus avant qu'ils
nous attaquent en gros et cette personne
a écrit une tribune au mois de février
pour pour dire qu'en fait considérer que
ce virus n'était pas d'origine naturelle
qu'il provienne d'un laboratoire c'était
une théorie du complot qu'il fallait
écarter en tant que tel il a il assez
bien manoeuvré par ce qu'il a il a écrit
cette tribune après il l'a fait signer
par par 27 scientifiques de renom et
donc il était un peu il est passé un peu
inaperçu parce qu'on savait pas que
c'était lui qui avait écrit cette
tribune
il était juste un des signataires parmi
beaucoup d'autres essais c'est paru
comme la communauté scientifique est
unanime a décrété que cette hypothèse de
laboratoire et une théorie du complot
et il se trouve quand même que cette
personne c'est quelqu'un qui travaillait
énormément depuis 10 15 ans avec avec le
laboratoire de one qui finançait même
leur participer au financement de leurs
travaux avec des fonds américains et est
donc en fait vous avez cette personne
qui et qui étaient partie prenante en
fait puisque ses amis il travaille
beaucoup avec eux notamment sur les
gains de fonction et qui a qui a diffusé
cette théorie qui ensuite est devenu
le responsable de la task force du lens
est sur la recherche de l'origine du
virus et qui est un expert de l'om est
ce qu'ils étaient dans l'équipe et était
celui qui s'exprimait le plus d'ailleurs
à one
donc en fait on à l'expert numéro 1
quasiment même si l'expert un vieux
numéro un qui est qui travaille avec le
suspect numéro 1 donc c'est un énorme
profil intéresse et c'est pas normal
cette personne ne devrait pas être à
cette place là il est tout à fait le
droit et c'est légitime d'avoir fait son
travail de collecte des verrues dû
travailler avec les chinois mais de le
mettre comme expert et celui qui en plus
va s'attacher à discréditer cette
hypothèse c'est bien c'est pas très
logique quoi
alexander semelle si intéressant parce
qu'il a un deuxième conflit d'intérêt je
pense aussi qu'on peut dire qu'une
sortie là il a envie je pense qu'on
prévienne les infections futur donc tout
l'intérêt de ce qui est fait de deux ses
travaux c'est également d'anticiper les
nouveaux virus qui risquent d'apparaître
et je pense que je me mets à sa place je
ne sais pas le ballon sa tête henri
j'imagine mais je me dis qu'il doit
avoir aussi un petit peu peur que si on
trouve que c'est issu d'un laboratoire
ou autre bah on voudrait réduire ce type
de recherche et arrêter de les faire et
pour ça représente peut-être pour lui
aussi une inquiétude parce que si on ne
fait pas ce genre de recherche
ça peut aussi désarmé en porte plus
qu'on ne l'a été
lorsque des infections respiratoires
arrive et le problème c'est qu'il n'ya
pas qu'un seul type d'infections
respiratoires qui peuvent nous tomber
dessus y en a beaucoup
donc je pense quelle question de fond
qui sous tend aussi qui est qui et qui
rend les choses extrêmement tendue et
dont il faudrait aussi sortir c'est
cette notion de est-ce qu'il faut
continuer à chercher dans ses
laboratoires la wii non comment dans
quelles conditions avait quelles
conditions de sécurité et je pense qu'il
faudrait des lier ces deux
problématiques
c'est à dire je pense qu'il est
clairement important que les normes de
sécurité soient remises au goût du jour
parce que effectivement
il ya le groupe drastique 6 par rapport
à mon sens ils partent un peu dans tous
les sens est certes une espèce de mille
fois que je reçois sort que j'ai déjà
interagit avec une personne parmi eux
c'est billy bob simpson et ils sortent
tellement de deux choses de
considérations qui ne sont pas
finalement scientifiques qui sont qui
sont effectivement pertinente mais qui
font que ça devient une histoire de
mille feuilles on est on sait pas trop
où ils veulent en venir et qui donne une
des suspicions et mais il n'y a pas de
contenu scientifique derrière on n'a pas
regardé les séquences qu'on n'a pas
regardé le dur quoi et et ça je pense
que c'est politiquement ça peut être
très dangereux de sur la base de sa veut
dire il faut plus qu'on surveille les
virus sont plus qu on fasse gaffe et c
est par contre ce qu'ils ont fait de
positif et ce qui est très intéressant
c'est qu'ils nous ont sortis des images
quand j'ai vu ces photos circulent et de
prélèvements qui avait été fait dans des
conditions qui n'étaient pas super clean
et hygiénique
on se rend compte qu'il ya des
infections sur certaines personnes qui
travaillent dans ces laboratoires lors
de la collecte notamment qui peuvent
être qu'ils peuvent être sans doute dû à
la manière de travailler
donc ça peut être important de renforcer
les manières de travailler c'est une
piste qui effectivement extrêmement
intéressante pour autant je pense que le
risque d'attraper un virus dans la
nature parce qu'il ya énormément de
virus dans notre corps en à nous-mêmes
là en ce moment on a des centaines de
virus dauphin 100 fois plus de virus qu
de que de cellules dans notre corps donc
on a plein de virus qui sont inoffensifs
pour nous mais de partout donc la
possibilité d'attraper un virus
quelconque dans la nature est quand même
assez élevé en termes de probabilité
le fait qu'il y ait une personne qui
collectent effectivement à certains
endroits des débits des vidéos est ce un
peu plus rare est un risque mais de la
même façon il existe un risque qui est
liée au fait qu'il ya plein de virus
partout
tout le temps et qu'on a énormément
énormément d'interaction avec des
animaux tout le temps vent le monde on
est des milliards d'individus avec des
milliards et des milliards d'interaction
avec les animaux les interactions avec
les animaux effectivement on pourrait
dire que ça datent du néolithique donc
ça donne pas d'hier
de même que la déforestation d'ailleurs
or quand il est quand on était tous dans
l'idée que c'était un animal sauvage et
notamment un pangolin le ms a réagi en
disant qu'il fallait arrêter la vente de
mammifères sauvages vivant sur les
marchés
les écologistes ont dit que c'était une
catastrophe qu'il fallait arrêter la
déforestation qu'il fallait arrêter
d'être en contact avec les animaux
sauvages pas etc
on a entendu tout ça s'il s'avérait que
c'est un laboratoire effectivement est
ce qu'il faudrait pas arrêter la
manipulation des virus parce que c'est
logiquement vu qu'on veut interdire les
choses à chaque fois il faudra bien
interdire quelque chose ce serait la
manipulation des biens sinon j'espère y
est oui dévia si je peux me permettre
sur le groupe drastique qui ne
regarderai pas les séquences en fait ils
regardent quand même pas mal du tout les
séquences et ils ont repéré notamment
passer des gens de drastiques qui ont
repéré que le virus ait raté g13 qui a
été sorti au mois de janvier par par le
laboratoire de one en fait avait déjà
été en partie séquencé en 2016 et
avaient été trouvés dans une mine ou des
démineurs avaient été contaminés parce
qu'il nettoyait cette mine il nettoyait
le guano des chauves-souris et ils
avaient été été malade en tout cas d'une
monnier atypique qui présentait tous les
tous les symptômes des cas graves de
sart skov 2 et donc bah ça c'est une
découverte de ce groupe drastique qui a
vraiment apporté beaucoup parce que sa
part peut-être dans tous les sens mais
c'est quand même assez efficace très
efficace
après leur dites moi votre question
excusez moi non je disais donc c'était
un pangolin on voulait arrêter la
déforestation interdire la vente de
mammifères sauvages vivant sur les
marchés si demain c'est un accident de
la bo est ce qu'il faut faire la même
manière interdire les manipulations de
verrues dans les labos c'est clair et ça
c'est aussi ce qui ce qui à ce qui a pu
inciter les scientifiques à accepter
aussi cette d'idées le labo c'est un
complot parce que ben oui si c'était un
virus travail est rendu plus dangereux
qui a causé cette pandémie forcément
l'opinion on dirait mais arrêtez de
arrêter ces trucs d'apprentis sorciers
quoi donc
donc oui et on a focalisé sur la faune
sauvage sur l'idée voilà la zone et la
faune sauvage particulièrement alors
quand
être les la plupart des zoonoses passe
par l'élevage et c'est très rare qu'il
ya une infection directement d'un animal
sauvage avec de la viande de brousse ou
quelque chose comme ça et qui se
comptent et qui contamine ensuite les
hommes parce qu' il peut y avoir des
contaminations mais en général ça ne
passe pas deux hommes ça reste de
l'animal sauvage à l'homme
et quand il ya des zoonoses avec qui
passe par des animaux ce qui est le plus
fréquent pour les maladies infectieuses
ça passe beaucoup plus par des élevages
où il va y avoir des contacts répétés
qui vont permettre au virus de s'adapter
à l'homme et ça ça nous amène à une
autre particularité du virus qui quand
on l'a découvert il était étonnamment
stable et ça c'est des chercheurs qu'on
trouvait sa condamnation était refusé de
publication mais c'est acquis
aujourd'hui les trois premiers mois du
de sart skov 2 jusqu'à cet épisode
italien vous avez un virus qui ne mute
quasiment pas tout cas pas de manière
significative et ça c'est pas habituel
parce que quand vous avez par exemple
sarce 1 pendant les trois premiers mois
de l'épidémie le virus et a beaucoup
muté comme c'est logique pour passer de
l'homme apprécié passe de l'animal à
l'homme pour s'adapter à l'homme est là
en fait et quand on a découvert le virus
il était immédiatement efficace et comme
s'il avait été préparé en fait pour pour
pour l'homme
donc c'est soit il a été préparé il a
été travaillé en laboratoire pour par
exemple avec des souris transgéniques
qui ont des cellules humaines qui ont
humanisé pour pour les expérimentés pour
travailler sur des programmes que ferait
un virus sur l'homme
ou alors il aurait le virus aurait pu
circuler à bas bruit chez les hommes et
avoir une mutation comme celle du site
figurines qu'il a rendu beaucoup plus
infectieux
mais ça on pourrait aussi retrouver des
virus proche
or on ne retrouve rien du tout alors
peut-être parce que la chine n'ouvre pas
les vannes de l'information mais en tout
cas le fait que ce virus soit soit tout
de suite très pour l'homme dès qu'on le
découvre c'est une particularité assez
étonnante et c'est ça qui est aussi
intrigué beaucoup de beaucoup de
chercheurs quoi sans dans sa malle
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans dans ce
laboratoire p4 de guyane
et pourquoi à votre avis est
indispensable de continuer de le faire
on ne manipule des virus sont les
expérimente sur les êtres humains qu est
ce qu on fait exactement je me suis je
pensais pas tout ce qui est fait il ya
des choses qui sont publiés des choses
sans doute qu'on ne sait pas exactement
d'habitude tout est publié d'habitude
dans un monde idéal on publie des choses
que c'est pas si grave que ça mais je
préfère pas dire que je suis tout ce qui
s'y passe parce que effectivement il ya
des choses qui sont un peu étonnante
même je suis d'accord pour dire des
choses étonnantes sur la communication
par exemple que il avait très très peu
de sarko qui vient de publier lorsqu'on
a lorsqu'on a cadré mais c'est venu par
contre d'un point de vue général je me
suis intéressé aux laboratoires qui sont
impliqués dans la guerre chimique
on avait un centre du coucher en france
par exemple été impliqué en guerre serbe
et n 10 un radiologique biologique
chimique c'est les différents risques
qui existent et les virus sont très
rarement considérés comme des bonnes
armes de guerre c'est pas quelque chose
que les militaires m développé pour les
rendre à en faire une arme de guerre ça
remonte déjà à la conférence de paix
gouache en 1959 où ils se sont rendus
compte que c'était
c'est une arme qui n'arrivent pas à bien
contrôler pourquoi parce que les
militaires ils ont besoin de enfin en
guerre on a besoin de contrôler
finalement ce qu'on fait on a besoin de
créer un maximum de casual ti c'est à
dire de victimes
à un moment donné et de les cibler de
savoir pour les touches à quel moment
les touches et comment on les touche
or pour un virus il faut le diffuser on
n'est pas sûr de la quel point il va se
diffuser on n'essaie pas sûr de son
efficacité
on n'est pas sûr de comment il va muter
à quel moment il va agir et s'il va pas
nous retomber dessus derrière donc c'est
très rarement à ça va jamais été
vraiment une une arme pour les
laboratoires quelque chose d'intéressant
à explorer comme arme offensive on va
dire c'est quelque chose qui a été mis
de côté au profit de toxines ou d'autres
éléments qui ont des effets beaucoup
plus directs qui sont beaucoup plus
faciles à gérer d'un point de vue
tactique et militaires ah ça non
ça n'empêche pas qu'il est possible
qu'on essaie d'en développer mais je
pense que l'intérêt principal c'est que
là depuis conakry sparkasse surtout
récemment et qu'on peut très facilement
modifier des séquences génétiques ce qui
fait le plus peur c'est de se dire qu
avec très peu de matériel
on peut très rapidement construire une
séquence génétique modifié des séquences
génétiques
est ce qu'il va faire le plus peur je
pense c'est le terrorisme biologique et
je pense que d'un point de vue
laboratoire dans ce qu'ils recherchent
plus ce peut-être ce qui doit être sans
doute fait le plus c'est d'essayer
d'anticiper ces tactiques ces choses là
c'est cette terrorisme biologique qui
pourrait avoir lieu je pense que c'est
c'est plutôt dans cet aspect des choses
on va essayer de modifier des virus et
c'est en ça que je trouve que le sascoc
2 n'est pas un bon candidat pour pour ce
type de recherches secrètes
confidentielles
parce que c'est pas quelque chose qui a
une mortalité énorme dès le départ c'est
pas c'est pas le genre de virus qui sert
d'armes ceci quelque chose qui déclenche
finalement une pandémie mondiale qui
affecte tout le monde mais qui ressemble
pas vraiment une arme la partie armes
je pense qu'on peut dire que sa
probabilité extrêmement basses je sais
pas si j'arriverai pour sûr ça que je
vais faire ce que mon avis ça ne l'est
pas tout dès lundi n'est pas
nécessairement une vérité oui larmes
c'est clairement pas quelque chose de
ces quasi nulles la probabilité je pense
d'une arme biologique comme dit monsieur
samuel c'est les virus ne ressemble pas
c'est pas c'est pas le type 2 une arme
biologique ça ressemble pas à sarko veut
du tout quoi et
et en plus bon ben ce serait quand même
assez stupide de faire une armée de la
relâcher à côté des laboratoires qui la
fabrique quoi donc ça peut rien que ça
ça peut écarter l'hypothèse d'une arme
biologique fait how one même et les
travaux sur les virus ne sont pas du
tout des travaux d'armes biologiques ce
sont des travaux qui sont faits pour
anticiper des virus pandémique est donc
de voir que comment un virus pourrait
devenir pandémique et c'est pas une arme
biologique comme le relâcher ces
connaître pour arriver à faire des
vaccins pour arriver à trouver des
thérapeutiques contre ces virus et ce
qu'ils cherchaient notamment ewan
c'était de huy de faire des vaccins en
fait des vaccins par exemple contre tous
les coronavirus et pour cela bon on sait
le coronavirus un peu plus virulent
celui qui allait faire mal pour trouver
la parade mais pas pour la relâcher dans
la nature
12 12 antoine flahault tout à l'heure
qui parlait de dunes d'un accident en
disant voilà ce serait ce n'était pas
intentionnel s'il ya eu une fuite de
laboratoire personne ne la souhaitait
mais effectivement il imaginait comme
vous venez de le faire que on y
travaille parce qu'on veut anticiper ce
qui peut se produire
on veut près anticiper les vaccins et
puis à un moment ça sort et
malheureusement ces plus virulents que
ce que l'on connaissait jusqu'à présent
on est on est assez d'accord sur la
partie 1 et sur la partie donc ça c'est
la partie qui est plus secrètes donc la
très improbable par un peu de quasiment
lecture sur la partie est ce que ça peut
être un accident dû à ces recherches où
on essaye d'anticiper les vaccins les
futurs que les futurs virus émergents
c'est justement sur ça que je pense que
ça peut être très préjudiciable de
vouloir à tout prix de vouloir à tout
prix dire que ça vienne en laboratoire
ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut pour des
raisons politiques ou autres dire non
mais ça peut pas venir du laboratoire
est fermée cette hypothèse je pense que
c'est très bien qu'elle soit ouverte
qu'on cherche mais
il faut aussi regarder ensuite la
probabilité que ça arrive dans la nature
naturellement que ça se passe par hasard
hélas quand on regarde les séquences
pour l'instant quand on entendrait
séquence génétique on est beaucoup plus
à se dire que ça aurait pu se produire
la nature de toute façon donc et ça
devait si ça aurait pu se produire de
toute façon c'est que ça devait se
produire en quelque sorte parce que ça
va dans vingt ans parce que tout le
temps des interactions des animaux il ya
tout le temps des mutations est le temps
des modifications que donc si si ça
tient la route pendant cette période de
temps c'est que c'est une question de
temps ça va se produire dans les dix ans
dans les quinze ans dans les vingt ans
et donc dans ce sens même si ça avait
été un accident de laboratoire c'est
quand même intéressant de maintenir ce
type de recherche en soi pour pouvoir
être armées le jour où ça arrive
maintenant est ce que il ya eu la
question savoir si c'est un accident ici
on a quand même pas mal d'éléments qui
nous indique que cette fois ci c'est
probablement pas trop le cas même si à
un sous-texte effectivement politique
c'est un petit peu compliqué il ya un
sous texte de données cachées de choses
qui sont pas montrés etc
moi mon hypothèse c'est peut-être qu'il
ya d'autres éléments qui ne veulent pas
montrer il y avait d'autres recherches
qui ne veulent pas montrer c'est plutôt
ça aussi ça peut être une explication au
fait qu'on ne souhaite pas montrer les
données par contre quand je regarde
vraiment les modifications les
différences génétiques qu'il y a c'est
pour moi une hypothèse très très faible
de se dire qu'il ya eu des ajouts
artificielle de l'homme le seul site qui
effectivement été pertinent c'est ce qui
a été discuté ce site de clivage à la
pure in et donc pour celui là on ne
trouve pas là la séquence en termes
protéique dans d'autres parce que dans
votre virus de la même famille par
contre ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'on a fait ses recherches uniquement à
l'échelle protéique c'est pas salé
chaîne protéique comme l'une des
mutations les mutations elles ont lieu à
des chaînes génétiques sur la rn et du
coup ce qui peut arriver très facilement
cédé recombinaison et on ne va pas
retrouver cette séquence
du site de clivage de la furie si si on
la cherche qu au niveau protéique et on
peut la retrouver au niveau génétique
par exemple il ya acheté a eu neuf qui
possède une séquence qui est extrêmement
homologue extrêmement similaires 14
nucléotides sur 19 qui sont identiques
et qui possède donc c'est un certes mais
qui est décalée en phase de lecture
c'est à dire que quentin ribosome
c'est à dire la molécule qui traduit cet
arn en protéines va le lire ben il va
pas lire ce site de clivage parce que la
séquence elle est décalée d'une case ce
qui vit trois par trois et que la
séquence elle commence il faut chaud il
faudrait dire en décalé pour ravir cette
séquence mais ça veut dire qu'il peut y
avoir une recombinaison avec sow hk une
offre par exemple mais ça a inséré
salahin serait en phase de lecture ce
site de clivage qui était décalée en
phase de lecture se rachetait l'unaf
oui je perrier il yad'autres vite ses
hobbies maison on peut dire aussi
qu'elle est assez improbable parce que
il ya des du quotidien qui sont pas tous
les nucléotides alors qu'on a une
insertion de 2,12 nucléotides qui ont un
rôle très particulier
et l'or l'or va dire leur côté naturel
ou étonnant il va notamment être été
être étudié de façon très approfondie ce
qui n'a pas encore été le cas jusqu'à
présent par une équipe de
bioinformatique sous la direction de
jacques van helden et qui va notamment
regarder une chose c'est que vous avez
pour faire des acides aminés vous avez
besoin de co2 qui est rassemblé 3 du
cléo ty et ce qui fait le style furie
des sons infectiosité sait qui est de
l'arginine qui est un acide aminé
basique s est un site poli basique parce
qu'il y en a plusieurs
et il se trouve que les colons qui
servent à coder l'arginine dansaert skov
2 ce sont deux que don qui sont cgg donc
ces trois nucléotides qui sont associés
et cggc déco donc on retrouve assez
rarement en fait naturellement dansaert
skov deux beaucoup moins que d'autres
colons qui codent l'arginine et or là on
les trouve deux fois on les trouve deux
fois de suite ce qui est peu étonnant et
il se trouve en revanche que quand on
veut faire de l'arginine insérer de
l'arginine dans des laboratoires là on
utilise très régulièrement cgg donc la
présence de ces nucléotides bain
pourrait être un signe qui amènerait des
probabilités vers le laboratoire et ça
ça va être fait dans une étude très
poussée qui va durer un an de
comparaison avec eux tous les virus
d'évolution des virus et on verra si
c'est cgg là le degré de probabilité en
gros qu'il soit naturel ou pas et ça
c'est une étude sur un cargo qui va être
fait en france qui va être fait en
france
je voudrais répondre aux mondiaux sur ça
s'est vite c'est très intéressant parce
que les cg j'ai justement balles et les
arginine elles peuvent être codées par
quatre colons a siégé eu cgc cga ou cgg
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que dans
la soute hk u9 les deux arginine s'il y
en a que deux elles sont toutes les deux
qu'au départ la séquence cgg on la
retrouve cette séquence et vg et quand
on cherche
cga ailleurs aussi c'est la théorie de
bill keller qui est préposé ça mais
justement on trouve précisément cette
séquence la syrah jusqu'à une heure
alors dernière question est ce que
d'ailleurs il n'ya pas d'art jean yves
nau rage mais c'est un peu technique
voilà dernière question pourquoi est ce
que c'est important de connaître enfin
dans l'espoir qu'on puisse le connaître
l'origine de de sart skov deux boys là
pour éviter ça recouvre trois peut-être
parce que c'est quand même comprendre
d'où vient cette pandémie basse et
éviter la prochaine et comme je vous le
disais les virus qui viennent la nature
c'est ça existe mais elle n'a pas tant
que ça en fait qui qui sont venus
naturellement par la faune sauvage qui
ont fait des pandémies comme ça et celle
ci s'est presque presque une première
avec un tel impact
et si elle vient de laboratoire ben
c'est quand même important de le savoir
parce que si on avait évité de faire ça
ou si on l'avait fait façon plus
précautionneuse n'y aurait pas eu la
pandémie et si ça vient des animaux
c'est important aussi de le savoir pour
savoir par quels animaux sont passés par
qu'est l'élevage pour contrôler ces
élevages pour contrôler les circuits en
fait que le circuit viennent du
laboratoire ou qui viennent de la faune
sauvage via les élevages c'est important
de le comprendre pour éviter qu'elle ait
d'autres virus reprennent le même chemin
en fait
alexander semelle mais bah c'est
intéressant parce que la grippe
espagnole par exemple on a mis longtemps
à retrouver de nouvelles venaient parce
qu'elle n'est pas espagnol la grippe
espagnole est donc souvent on met un peu
de temps à retrouver les origines et à
retrouver d'où ça vient et moi je trouve
que la conclusion intéressante si
l'objectif est de se dire qu'il faut
éviter que ça se reproduise c'est
effectivement un but très noble et que
tout le monde partage justement est ce
que est ce que est ce que du coup il
faut se dire il faut fermer les
laboratoires ou est ce que parce que
même si ce même si ça s'était échappé
d'un laboratoire dont je me dis il
n'empêche que dans la nature ça se
produit aussi on a des exemples
historiques en a pas mal et du coup il
vaut mieux anticiper un petit peu et
préparé mais dans ce cas il faudrait
choisir lé strict des normes plus
strictes pour les laboratoires être plus
sûres
faire attention à ce qu'on fait or pour
l'instant de ce que je sais des p4g pas
été reçus de one j'ai pas visité de mes
yeux etc
mais c'est extrêmement difficile qu'il y
ait des problèmes sur des laboratoires
de cette haute sécurité
il ya par exemple une histoire une
fausse rumeur qui circule énormément sur
un sdf qui se seraient introduits dans
un p4 en france à lyon alors
effectivement il ya un sdf qui s'est
introduit dans dans le laboratoire p4
entre guillemets mais c'est dans la
partie administrative n'a jamais eu
accès dans les zones dangereuses il a
été tout de suite confrontées
il y avait tout de suite une personne
qui l'a vu ça n'a duré que quelques
minutes
enfin c'était ça n'a rien à voir et
c'est des endroits qui sont extrêmement
sécurisé aussi bien contre l'intrusion
mais aussi contre les échappements de
toute molécule et des niveaux de
sécurité qui sont d'un très très beaux
standards c'est extrêmement difficile
que j'aie quelque chose s'échappe d'un
laboratoire
je pense que c'est plutôt elle aussi une
hypothèse de liés aux laboratoires c'est
ce qui est plutôt une hypothèse de type
zone ce qui se serait produit à la
collecte et la collecte c'est moins
fréquent qui est des collectes qu' il ya
des interactions entre l'homme et
l'animal
quoique qui sont quotidiennes dans le
monde avec plein d'élevage intensif
comme problème de ce type là donc moi je
pense que même même si on cherche encore
à savoir d'où ça vient même si on peut
continuer à chercher la réponse on peut
déjà répondre à cette question là il
faut déjà répondre à cette question là
de dire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
je pense qu'il faut absolument continuer
à ceux anticipés à peu à se prémunir
peut-être élever les niveaux de sécurité
pour vérifier le niveau de sécurité des
laboratoires ça c'est un problème
maintenir le niveau de sécurité qu'on a
déjà
et puis faire attention aussi à notre
environnement peut-être se poser des
questions sur la manière dont on traite
l'environnement l'écologie
notre consommation etc et et la
concentration d'animaux pour l'élevage
vous remercie tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci de nous avoir
suivis et rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]